the movie straight outta contempt comes
out
i'm so excited i'm from l.a so this
movie is particularly close to my heart
i saw it in theaters three times because
i'm cruising the internet devouring
everything i can about this movie
i come across the casting call now this
movie has already come out and i'm no
actress
i wouldn't actually audition but i just
wondered
hypothetically if i did what role would
i get
so look at the casting call and i'm
going down the categories and i start at
the top
the a girls the casting call reads
these are the hottest of the hottest
models
must have real hair no extensions
well since i have 20 inches of brazilian
hair extensions on my head
doesn't quite apply to me but that's
fine i go to the next category
the bee girls the casting call reads
these are fine girls long natural hair
must have light skin beyonce is the
prototype here
light skin also not me
and might i add not even beyonce made
the cut to be an a girl
but that's fine i go to the next
category
the sea girls the casting call reads
these are african-american girls can't
have extensions
must be medium to light skin toned
now maybe back when i lived in boston
in the middle of the winter can i get
away with being
medium skin toned but since i've come
back to sunny california
where i spent all my free time baking in
the sun not so much
so i scroll all the way down to the last
category
the d girls the casting call reads
these are african-american girls poor
not not in good shape must have a darker
skin tone
a darker skin tone well
i guess that's me a d girl
when i first read this i felt betrayed
any given year there are just a handful
of movies starring black actors and
actresses
just a handful of opportunities when
people can see actresses that look like
me on the big screen
i see they were fierce and beautiful and
desirable
so i felt betrayed but even in these
small circles where i'm allowed to feel
beautiful
and so served aside for those with more
favorable features light skin
light eyes long soft real hair
but the more i thought about it the more
the feeling of betrayal slipped away
from more familiar feeling of that's
just the way it is
because in my world this phenomenon is
all too familiar
something just as sinister and subtle as
racism
colorism the discrimination of those
with a darker skin tone
typically amongst individuals within the
same racial or ethnic group
the story of colorism in the u.s begins
with slavery the mass
rate of african slave females by white
male slave masters
gave birth to a cohort of mixed-race
slave children
these mixed-race slaves were related to
the slave masters and had more anglo
features
and were given preferential treatment
and allowed to work inside the house
doing less strenuous work
as opposed to the darker skinned slaves
that's worked out in the fields doing
more laborious work even after slavery
was abolished
white still gave more preferential
treatment to black the had more angle
type features
give them better access to jobs housing
and education
the thing is though even within the
black community
black people use skin tone and facial
features to discriminate against each
other
they would only allow entrance into
sororities fraternities or elite social
clubs
to blacks that were able to display
anglo-type features
they would go through a series of tests
to see if you fit the bill
one well-known test was the brown paper
bag test
where if you were lighter than a brown
paper bag you're in
but if you're dark in the brown paper
bag
you're out another well-known test was
the pencil test
where they would take a pencil and run
it through your hair
to make sure that it's straight enough
that the pencil wouldn't get stuck
the last test was called the shadow test
where they would take a flashlight
and shine it against your profile and
look at the shadow
that your profile made against the wall
and if it matched that
of a typical white person's profile you
were fine
but if it didn't you're out
now though these practices are no longer
in effect today
the effects of them are still very much
so present i remember a common
compliment i would often get in middle
school and high school often told me
about other black males
it went to the effect of oh you're so
pretty for a dark-skinned girl
and it doesn't help that the media
continues to place a premium on lighter
skin
by retouching and photoshopping the the
skin of
actresses of color before putting them
on the cover of magazines
as can be seen here
here here
and even here
now colorism is not just isolated to the
us
its effects are global as best
illustrated by the skin lightening and
skin bleaching cream all over the world
in india and asia alone skin lightening
and skin bleaching
is a multi-billion dollar business
despite the harmful toxins that are
present in these products
people are still willing to take the
risk and use them in order to achieve
what they are led to believe
is beautiful and beauty products have
flocked on this insight
well-known brand vaseline even partnered
with facebook come up with an app
that would lighten the skin of your
profile picture in order to promote
their skin lightening cream
and you can't travel throughout asia
without being inundated by
advertising on commercials that promise
happiness and success
if you could just be a little bit
lighter
studies have shown that these messages
that we see
at a young age have a profound effect on
us
in 2010 cnn did a study where they
interviewed young children
just five six and seven years old and
asked them to place values and
attributes to people based on their skin
tone here's a clip from
from that study the smart child and why
is she the smart child
because she is
white okay show me the dumb chow
and why is she the dumb child because
she plays
well show me the ugly child
and why she the ugly child because she
believed
show me the good looking child
and why is she the good looking child
because she likes skating
these messages that we see at such a
young age and these messages that we
internalize
they stay with us they stayed with me
although i deny it and i block it out
and i say i'm strong i'm smart i'm
accomplished i'm beautiful i'm here at
stanford and i'm not a d
girl the stuff these messages
they stayed with me and they manifest in
this voice that makes me question makes
me doubt and makes me think but wait
am i d girl stays with me
and so now whenever someone gives me a
compliment or says oh you look nice you
look pretty the voice
fills in the rest of the sentence with
for a dark skin girl
it stays with me and it makes me
question my intentions
because even though i say that i have
these extensions just for fun and that i
like them that voice says no
you got them because you're trying to
reach a beauty standard you can actually
never attain it stays with me
even as i go to send a simple text
message that voice
in my head tells me that i should be
embarrassed or ashamed when i scroll
all the way to the end to the last
darkest emoji it stays with me
but i don't want it to stay with me and
the good thing is it doesn't have to
because these beauty preferences that we
have
they're not something we're born with
they're learned
and if they're learned they can be
unlearned
among us our ceos and co-founders
directors of marketing
you all are the arbiters of what society
considers beautiful by deciding who you
choose put in your advertising or who
you choose to be the face of your brand
so when you have the opportunity to make
that choice make the unconventional
choice
and those of us that consume these
messages we play a role too
because the first step to change is
awareness
and now everyone in this room is a
little more aware
and will see the world just a little bit
differently
and we don't have to passively accept
what society tells us to think is
beautiful
we can question it we could challenge
the status quo
because when we do we get one step
closer
to broadening the standard of beauty and
creating a society where the world can
see
that d-girls are beautiful too thank you